hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested but I haven't
had the opportunity to cover it until
now it's a game from round four of the
United States Championship and displayed
between Fabiano Caruana you all know him
it's he's the world chess championship
Challenger and 33 year old Georgian
chess players via a zoria now if you ask
me before this US Championship who who's
really zoria was I would definitely say
I have no idea but he's definitely
someone who did not come here just to
make an appearance like I said he's a 33
year old Grandmaster from Georgia now he
represents the United States but he did
play three times in the Olympiad where
he represented Georgia and he had he had
a lot of great successes throughout his
life in 2005 he played in the World Cup
in the year 2000 he won he won the world
under-16 championship and also won the
Kasparov Cup in Moscow and in in 2001
2001 was an excellent year for him
because he won the Europe Championship
under 16 and also that year he won the
Europe Jam pionship under 18 so he
completely obliterated the field next
year in 2002 he also won the under-20
Europe Chess Championship and here he is
playing against Fabiana Caruana and the
rating difference is somewhat of a
significance between them as fabi's
rated I believe twenty eight hundred and
four and thus via di Soria is rated
$25.99 so there is over 200 euro points
of a difference between them and Fabi
does have the white pieces so let's see
this game Fabi opens with E 4 we have E
5 9 to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to c4
so the Italian game Bishop to c5 we have
the Joko piano c3 this is the main line
Knight to f6 D 3 and d 6 now we have
castles and Osorio goes for h6
you could continue with something like
Bishop to g4 but it doesn't post that
much of a problem for white he has this
Bishop is on c4 it's not on e2 but after
something like h3 and Bishop 2a
five you can go for that ninety-two
rocky one-night f1 and Knight g3 idea
where you will kick the bishop away to
g6 for example Knight bTW to a6 rook e1
black castles now Knight f1 and after
black plays something you will simply
kick away the bishop and you will break
this pin on the knight so it's not a
problem but in the game h6 by zoria rook
to e1 we have castles h3 a5 9 B to d2
and a for now nice to f1 by Fabi still
deciding where to go
III or g3 and to d7 by zoria and first
d4 by Fabi so this is now kind of a kind
of the middle game of this game and
before we continue I did prepare some
two nice photos of via di saw really we
have this one and this one
it seems that whenever you see him
playing just somewhere he's always
wearing some sort of a hat so I find
this found is very interesting and I
decided to share this with you so
they're just putting that out there and
now let's continue here after d4 we have
Bishop to b6 not wanting to break
tension in the center black could go for
something like e capture 74 and
immediately break the tension
but after C captures Bishop to b6 e 5
pawn captures pawn captures and night to
h7 it's not that this is a worse
position for black but simply simply
it's not very very creative to play like
this is black and there's really nothing
to hope for here
so after d4 Bishop to b6 and night to g3
and one more thing I did I did try a
different approach in using my
microphone so the sound of the pieces
may be a bit different if if you can if
you can sense some difference in the
sound of the moving pieces do share in
the comments I'm really interested if if
this will be a bother for you I will
revert it back the way it was
so rook to e8 we have Bishop to f1 and
now Queen to b8
we have d5 now closing the centre 93 7
and
to h4 now Fabi wants to grab a hold of
that f5 Square King to h7 Queen to f3
controlling f5 even further Queen to d8
as the Queen is no longer useful on b8
now after the Knights move the Queen can
come into the game and a Soria will be
interested in exchanging Queens Bishop
to d2 we have night e 2g 892 a nighty to
f5 and now g6 kicking the night away 9 3
3 King g7 and now Knights the c4
attacking the bishop on b6 Bishop to e7
and now Bishop to e3 offering the
exchange of bishops with a brush-up
capture screen captures and night to h7
now making room for the Queen to come
into the game now Fabi plays f4 we have
b5 now kicking away this night from c4
nice the d2 and now he captures on f4
Queen captures and Queen to f6 and fog
we did get an edge from the opening
which is normal they played the Italian
game he had the white pieces he
controlled more space he pushed d5 but
it seems that is Oriya pretty much sold
all of his opening problems he he kicked
fabi's pieces all the way back and now
he is offering a trade of Queens and if
Bobby agreed to this for example Queen
captures Knight captures then this night
would now occupy very nice square and
fabi's pieces aren't all that great
this Knight doesn't really have a bright
future and just night really doesn't
have anywhere to go either the bishop is
kind of silly looking on f1 not not the
greatest position for white so here a
Fabi declines the trade Queen e3 we have
nice to e7 Queen to f3 now Fabi offers a
trade of Queens and rook a to be 8 by
Soria Fabi plays a3 not allowing b4 we
have c5 and rook a to d1 you could also
maybe want to break this pawn chain by
by playing D captures on c6 and Poisson
but after Knight captures again it's
it's nothing nothing good for white here
this night is coming to e5 Bishop can
always come to c6 the the rooks can be
doubled on the e-file and black will
have a better position even though this
Sixpoint is slightly weak it's okay
after c5 we have rook a to be one and
now Knight to c8 I would have Queen to
e3 now Fabi doesn't wanna trade Queens
anymore
Knight to the b6 and now Knight to f3
here after Knight b6 Knight captures on
d5 was was the idea so night to b6 game
with a tempo this point is pinned as the
rock design the Queen on e3 so after
Knight to f3 Knight to g5 now offering a
trade of nights and nights to h2 we have
night back to h7 now Bishop to e2 and
Queen to g5 is Orion out again offers a
trade of Queens and it seems that the
Queen's in this game are being used only
only as a as the means to Riemann over
the pieces his Oriole wants Fabi to
capture the Queen so he can get his nice
night to a nice square and the Fabi
would also enjoy such a thing so Fabi
declines this Queen to f2 and we have
Queen back to f6
zoria repeats the position and again
offers the trade of Queens now on f6
Fabi the clients and repeats Queen to
III is Oriya once again repeats Queen to
g5 and now if Fabi were to repeat Queen
back to f2 we would basically have a
draw by threefold repetition but Fabi
plays Queen to f3 he declines the draw
and here is Soria misses a great
opportunity to gain advantage from the
position by pushing age 5 and H for
grabbing more space on the Kings side
but he repeats Queen to f6 as here you
can maybe see the difference is Oriya
what the black pieces would be would be
more than happy to grab a draw from Fabi
as there is more than 200 yellow points
difference between them but here if Abby
can again repeat Queen to e3 and is
Oriole would most likely go for Queen to
the Queen to g5 but Bishop to d3 so
Queen captures on f3 is Oriya finally
exchanges Queens Knight captures and now
f6 preparing to expand on King side and
also this night this pawn controls c5
and g5 very nicely now we have h4 h5 and
King to have to alpha B brings the King
into the action Knight to a fate night
to d2 Knight to c8 and
to be one preparing to push be three we
have 9 3 7 9 2 g - f 1 9 2 g 8 and now
tonight's the e3 so both players are
trying to make use of their knights
knife to h6 now with ideas of ring the
night all the way to g4 so Bishop to e2
controlling you g4 one more time and f5
also fighting for the center but also
controlling g4 one more time and here
you could play it captures on f5 but
then again after Knight captures Knight
captures Bishop captures you have to
move the rook has its attacks from the
bishop and then after 97 this night is
coming to e5 it's a wonderful position
for black to play so Bobby doesn't want
to capture an i-5 rather he plays b3
immediately now we have a capture some
b3 row capture some b3 and then now see
for kicking the rook away from their
rope to b4 and now F captures on e4 rook
to be one with ideas of pushing a four
immediately as the rook and b8 would
come under attack if one characters so
rook to e8
we have a four now if B captors on a 4
then the C pawn becomes weak but there's
really no better move here rook captures
rook captures pawn captures and now
Knight captures in c4 we have 90 to f7
and now rook to b6 aligning the rook
with the King on g7 so King to have six
bringing the King deeper into the
position and also getting him out of the
seventh rank bishop the d1 attacking the
a4 pawn rook to e8 preparing to push the
a4 pawn and now nice to be nice to b6
attacking the rook and also the pawn
rook moves and here we have a night eat
the c4
we have Bishop to b5 attacking the
knight and now Knight back to e2 it's a
very interesting move here far we did
get the opportunity to play Bishop
captures on a4 and after Bishop captures
Knight captures he would he would again
grab a pond and the me material will
once again be equal but instead of this
far he goes for Knight to e2 he will
have time to capture day for porn but
now he turns his attention to the e4
pawn with a very interesting tactic
Bishop to d3 defending the pawn we have
King to e3 and now you see the idea we
have Knight to Knight to e5 and Bishop
captures on a4 and here g5 is played
this is this was fabi's idea now King f5
what idea of protecting the e4 pawn does
not work because Roxy 7 is coming with a
with rook c8 next exchanging this rook
and then the d6 pawn will become very
weak
for example Nagi for check King moves
now King f4 now comes rook c8 you have
to capture the rook because your knight
will become will be n prize so ro
captures Knight captures and now the d6
pawn is weak the only way to defend it
is to push III King captures pawn
captures king characters and now King to
e5 will defend defend the pawn but after
Knight to e7 fafa B would be up upon
with relatively good chances of winning
this game
so after this Bishop to a4 as you as you
saw King f5 doesn't work so he's already
finds another plan
he plays g5 we have H capture son g5
King captors and g5 and the now Knight
captures on e4 Bishop captures in ki
King capture so after all of this now
it's again Fabi who is up up a pawn but
Soria has the past H pawn which can also
be very dangerous here at night f2 g6
was played Knight to d7 rook to c8
attacking the pawn and now Bishop to c6
Fabi defends it but by doing so also
loses a pawn Knight captures pawn
captures and rook captures so the
material is once again equal we have
King to d4 now comes Knight to f4
attacking the G to pawn and here far we
placed c4 you can't protect it with
something like g3 then 92 simply checks
the king and wins the pawn back
so here c4 was played
we have Knight captures now he's already
eyes upper pawn and now kink the d5 and
here you'll see what fabi's idea was we
have a look to see it and now Knight the
b6 attacking the rook and also
when the rock moves then the king will
grab the pawn on d6 and start pushing
his c4 pawn but here is the problem and
this is what Fabian missed his Oriya
will not move the rook or anything
rather he's already played nice - III
check and this attacks the king and the
pawn here if you play King captures on
d6 you get Knight captures on c4 with
check King captures rook captures and
now I Soria will be left with this past
H pawn and it is a rock ending with only
one point up but white cannot stop the
point as the white king is too far back
he will never be able to get anywhere
near the pond or the king
so after this night - III move we have
king to e6 and the now comes rook to c6
and you'll see the idea Fabi plays King
to d7 now of course if Knight captures
on c4 then Fabi will grab his Orioles
rook but here comes the problem Knight
c4 nevertheless King captors on c6 and
now comes Knight to a5 check and this
was his aureus big plan now the king is
in check the rock is under attack and
the king the King cannot keep defense of
the rook can be 7 because the c7 square
is covered by the pawn so King captures
rook knife captor son b7 check and the
King moves and now comes King to a for
making room for this past point to
become a queen so can the knight stop
this well Knight to c4 was played we
have h 4 nights to d2 we have h 3 nights
to f1 and here night the night to d8
King to d4 and now knife to f7 it's very
interesting I mean also very important
you have to get this night all the way
to g4 from g4 this night has to protect
III and also h2 and then only then will
this be winning for black if you try to
win this immediately you can run into a
lot of tricks for example King your
three king d3 King F 293 and then if you
start H 2 with ideas of grabbing the
Queen you can always lose two idea I'm
not loose but miss your chances for a
win because this is now check and after
the
you're left with a knight and you can
never win this game anymore so after
this King to d4 Knight to f7 we have
King to d5 and now comes Knight to e5 we
have King back to d4 now we have Knight
to g4 King to D 3 and now King to f3 and
it was in this position that
Fabiana Caruana roaches championship
challenger resigned at the game and a
great victory for V at essaouira yeah
and I mean a really great victory as
Fabia lately does not lose a lot of
games and it's interesting yeah for the
game is lost now because blacks plan is
very simple he will simply play king of
two and now it's important to see that
there is no a nice to H 2 because the
night covers H 2 and there is no night
to e3 with the trick we've just shown H
294 because the knight is also covering
e3 so here you would have to simply move
a knight and then H 2 and there is no
stopping after something like this there
is no stopping H 1 queen white has no
more tricks so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoy it and it's very
important to say that we as we editorial
air in this tournament who defeated both
Fabiano Caruana and Hikaru Nakamura
so quite a player at the moment he is
currently in fifth place because he lost
two games he had the worst start of the
tournament possible in round one he drew
against Jeffries young and then he lost
in round two against Robson and in round
three against Sam Franklin so from the
first three rounds a draw in two losses
and only then this nice victory against
against Fabi
so yeah once again that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank even boys each for a contribution
to my channel think a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you all